the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC well I want to start today with how
Republicans are continuing to use
anti-intellectualism and
pseudo-intellectualism to divide America
and very specifically and overtly to try
to win elections not in a vague sense
they're trying to win today in Georgia
by using anti-intellectualism to divide
America and to create this Narrative of
Good and Evil right and wrong Elite and
working man or whatever sort of black
white framing you want to use I was
doing research for a story that I was
going to bring to you today and it's a
clip of Republican Center John Kennedy
where he talks about oh don't let these
high IQ people this that and the other
thing all in a defense of why we should
or Georgians should vote tonight in the
December runoff uh December 6 runoff
which is which is today in Georgia for
Herschel Walker rather than Raphael
Warnock the framing being okay Herschel
Walker might be kind of dumb but don't
let these high IQ people tell you that
they're the ones you should be voting
for or whatever the case may be and in
doing my research for this I came across
a really great article that says just
about everything that needs to be said
as well as it can be said by Jason
Easley and Sarah Jones and so we're
going to link to the article
um but but it gives us a great jumping
off point for this discussion and in the
article uh Jason and Sarah write how
Republicans are using
anti-intellectualism to divide America
Senator John Kennedy's comments on high
IQ stupid people show that Republicans
have weaponized anti-intellectualism to
to divide America
anti-intellectualism is nothing new in
the Republican party they write but
Senator John Kennedy used Herschel
Walker's lack of intellect as a selling
point while urging Republicans to
despise anyone with a high IQ now we're
going to look at a clip and of course
the irony of this is well you might
figure out the irony but let's play the
clip first
for everything
you know why
because they think they're smarter and
more virtuous than the American people
these woke
high IQ stupid people they're easy to
recognize
easy to recognize this is there are so
many subtexts here but let's keep
playing it
they hate George Washington ah they hate
Thomas Jefferson
they hate Dr Zeus and they hate Mr
Potato Head Dr Zeus by the way okay
these woke
hi cute stupid people they walk around
they walk around with Ziploc bags of
kale
that they can eat to give them energy
now if you want food does provide energy
to the body that's true eat chaos
to me like I'd rather be fat
and these okay there is so there's a lot
there to comment on and I'm not going to
comment on a lot of it
notice how John Kennedy talks about how
you can tell
who the high IQ stupid people are
one of the Tells to some degree is the
way people speak of course and maybe in
hearing John Kennedy speak because of
his accent maybe he's not supposed to
read like one of those high IQ stupid
people but we know that John Kennedy is
playing a character and part of the
character is a character developed to
appeal to exactly the types of people
that vote for Republicans because when
you actually try to figure out well who
is this John Kennedy guy John Kennedy
has a degree from Vanderbilt University
and then he has a law degree from the
University of Virginia School of Law and
then he went to Magdalene College after
that I'm trying to see what exactly
degree he has uh he has from there
Magdalene College he got a
um an additional degree there okay I'm
not sure exactly what he does he has a
Juris doctor that that is I know that we
don't in the U.S we don't refer to
lawyers as doctors in some other
countries like in Argentina lawyers are
generally called doctors just sort of
like like Dr Jill Biden is a doctor of
Education doesn't matter he has a
doctorate a Juris doctor he is one of
those very people but at the same time
he has developed a character wherein he
is not one of those people and it's
because anti-intellectualism is a
product
it's a package that is being sold to
divide America regardless of who
actually are the so-called high IQ or
low IQ people now you could argue John
Kennedy doesn't have a lot of Street
smarts maybe not a lot of common sense
but to argue that he is dramatically
different than these high IQ people uh
that he is criticizing is is really just
not the case and this is exactly how
they frame these arguments when it's
convenient when it's convenient to them
they say listen
we've got brilliant people in our party
Ron DeSantis who went to Harvard I think
if I recall correctly Ted Cruz who went
to Harvard
when it's not convenient going to
Harvard and even getting a law degree
from Harvard I mean you've got it's
sometimes it's great to have a law
degree from Harvard sometimes it's a
signal of Epic never-ending wokeness and
progressivism and Harvard is racist then
going to Harvard is bad it's just
whatever is convenient and when you go
to them and you actually say I I haven't
heard it done but if you go to them and
you say hey
is having a law degree from Harvard a
good thing or a bad thing when it comes
to who should be leading the country
well you know that depends David that
really depends it's much more
complicated than that oh so then it's
not really about having a law degree
from Harvard is it right now they're
using all of this simply to try to
justify voting for Herschel Walker
because they don't want a republican
Rafael Warnock to continue being a
senator uh representing the state of
Georgia that's as simple as it is the
topic more generally if it's interesting
to you we've done so much content on it
a few things you can check out on the
YouTube channel include the video why
are people falling for fake
intellectualism you can also find the
video on my YouTube channel why is
pseudo-intellectualism so appealing and
then lastly and there's many more but of
the three that I'll highlight if you
want to see this ideology applied
specifically to something more recent
like the pandemic the video the
disgusting anti-intellectualism in the
covid-19 pandemic you can also just
search my YouTube channel for words like
intellectual or intellectualism and you
will find a treasure Trove of content
let's talk about the rights sick
depraved obsession with a guy named
Hunter Biden now I know many of you are
evaluating and thinking about
how has the presidency of Joe Biden gone
has he done good things has he done bad
things has he not done enough things or
is he doing too much is his perspective
on gun safety the right perspective
we're talking about the president
there is a large swath of people and
many of them are in positions of power
many of them are people who have large
microphones some literally large and
some proverbial metaphorically large
microphones who are obsessed not with
Joe Biden they're not alone with Joe
Biden but with a guy named Hunter bite
now Hunter Biden has no role whatsoever
in his father's Administration
simply none it's not like Jared Kushner
or Ivanka who were involved in their
fathers and father-in-law's
Administration Hunter is not trying nor
does he have any role in Joe Biden's
Administration and yet there are many on
the right who are obsessed with him
there's a really good article which we
will link to in the description to the
YouTube video call up by Michael tomasky
for New Republic it was published
yesterday called there's nothing
Stranger Than the rights fixation with
Hunter Biden now the article is
excellent
it depends how you want to interpret
this but on the one hand it is a bizarre
hyper fixation on Hunter Biden from the
right on the other hand it's also kind
of not and we're going to talk about
that uh the sort of catalyst for this
article which uh I encourage you to read
was the Twitter files bombshell that
flopped over the weekend a Twitter
thread published by journalist Matt
taibi
um and a couple important things to
highlight here the article reads what
exactly is at the root of the rights
Hunter Biden obsession
at its simplest level the hunter Saga is
just a potential Achilles heel for a
president they want to defeat in 2024
assuming Joe Biden runs I think that
that's right I think that they don't
really care about Hunter Biden
in and of itself but they care about
Hunter Biden as a possible way to hurt
Joe Biden in 2024. but that has never
quite explained the article goes on the
manic quality of the drive to turn
Hunter into the symbol and standard
bearer of the democratic party and of
liberalism generally it had to have
something to do I always thought with
the notion that Hunter represents the
licentiousness with which conservatives
associate liberals his drug use his
sketchy affair with his dead brother's
wife and now his entry into the effect
and vaguely Un-American Manhattan art
world but this weekend things got even
weirder
and in ways that were so sorted it took
me a while to even understand what was
going on
if you had the good fortune or sense not
to crawl down this particular Rabbit
Hole over the weekend fear not I won't
drag you into the depths that I
descended the briefest recap is this on
Friday Elon Musk tweeted he would reveal
how Twitter supposedly covered up the
hunter Biden scandal in October 2020
Matt taibi posted some of the emails
found on Hunter's hard drive some showed
the Biden campaign asking Twitter to
refrain from posting certain material
that's basically it
in some quarters of the right this is
the biggest scandal in the history of
the Republic because it allegedly proves
that Biden used his governmental power
he by the way didn't control any of the
government at the time to set fire to
the Constitution musk tweet it if this
isn't a violation of the Constitution's
First Amendment what is there are a
couple different things that I believe
are important to mention here first of
all
if we want to go back to the source of
all of this the hunter Biden laptop
itself
what's in a sense ironic is that
everything there that definitively
touches Joe Biden makes Joe Biden look
really good what I mean by that is that
there are lots of allegations the right
makes about the Joe Biden connection
they say Well when the messages refer to
the big guy getting a cut
it's about Joe Biden there's no evidence
of that at this point at the end time
could it be true sure there is no
evidence of that at this point in time
the things we know relate to Joe Biden
that we have uncovered based on these
emails are that Joe Biden really loves
Hunter
that Joe Biden really
expressed empathy for Hunter's drug use
and and drug problems Etc
um the voice message where he says it's
Dad I called to tell you I love you the
right tried to make this uh uh frame
Biden as being weak
the truth is Don Jr probably wishes his
dad talked to him that way and told him
he loved him uh that relationship
doesn't really seem quite so good but
the truth is that everything we
definitively have linked to Joe Biden
from the laptop makes him look pretty
good and the reality is that
conservatives don't really have
the indictment of Joe Biden anywhere
that exists of trump and that's why they
are making it all about Hunter Biden and
in his article Michael tomasky
eventually gets to this exact conclusion
the hunter Crusade he writes is thus
driven not only by pursuit of Scandal to
hang around his father's neck it is
rooted in the rights antique and cruel
value system which most Americans no
longer share should Republicans catch
hunter in some genuinely corrupt or
illegal Arrangement so be it let him pay
his debt to society if they don't they
will be left wondering why America
doesn't share their seething hatred of a
man whom the Jesus they claim to worship
would have counseled us to regard with
compassion
this is fundamentally what this is all
about and there's two sides to this now
to get back to the bizarre nature of the
obsession on the one hand it is bizarre
they're obsessed with someone so
meaningless not as a person every person
has value meaningless in the context of
figuring out is the country going in the
right or wrong direction
What policies of Joe bidens have been
helpful versus damaging to the economy
or to foreign policy or whatever it's
meaningless in that sense and that is
bizarre but at the same time
hyper focus on irrelevant issues has
been the name of the game for this
Republican party for four six probably
more like eight or even closer to ten
years at this point in time and that
really shouldn't surprise us at all
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
the David packman show is a community
funded program it's funded by the
audience through the membership program
you can find out about the membership
program and of course sign up very very
quickly and easily at joinpakman.com you
can also use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get yourself a discount members
get access to the Daily bonus show an
extra show we do every day for our
members you also get commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
invitations to the members only Town
Hall events and much more you can sign
up at joinpakman.com well folks it is
starting Donald Trump hid a 19.8 million
dollar loan from a North Korea linked
company while he was President very
quickly paid that off never disclosed it
and the questions are growing and
growing and growing a number of
important and detailed articles to look
at including a Forbes article called
Trump owed hidden debt while in office
this is clearly only the very beginning
and remember
his tax returns haven't even leaked yet
the house Ways and Means Committee has
them but they have not yet even leaked
let's dig into this first story uh
Donald Trump's business attracted so
much scrutiny during his time in office
that it would be easy to conclude that
all the information about its foreign
entanglements would be out by now but
it's not
buried in a heap of recently released
financial paperwork sits a surprising
Revelation Donald Trump had a foreign
creditor he failed to disclose while
running for president in 2016 and after
assuming office in 2017. the documents
compiled by the Trump organization and
obtained by the New York attorney
general show a previously unreported
liability of 19.8 million dollars listed
as LP Daewoo
the debt stems from an agreement Trump
struck to share some of his licensing
fees with Daewoo which is a South Korean
conglomerate that partnered with Trump
on a project near the UN headquarters in
New York City
Trump eliminated the debt five and a
half months into his tenure as president
according to the documents he seems to
have acted with urgency to wipe the
liability off his balance sheet from
2011 to 2016 the balance stayed static
at 19.8 million paperwork capturing
Trump's Financial picture as of June 30
2017 five months into his presidency
appear to show the balance dropped to
4.3 million Trump got rid of the debt
altogether shortly after that Daewoo was
bought out of its position on July 5
2017. doesn't say who paid off the loan
although the debt appeared on the Trump
organization's internal paperwork it did
not show up on Trump's public Financial
disclosure report
documents he was required to submit to
Federal officials while running for
president and after taking office
Trump's former CFO Alan weisselberg told
the New York Times in 2016 his boss
disclosed all debt connected to
companies in which Trump held a 100
percent stake on the documents that was
not true it's also important to
understand that there is a North Korean
connection here although it is not
necessarily the most important or
titillating aspect of this the very same
Forbes article reads
there's little doubt that if the Work
World had known about the debt while
Trump was President it would have
sparked conflict of interest concerns
perhaps heightened by daewoo's
historical ties to North Korea in the
mid-1990s The Firm was the only South
Korean company permitted to operate a
business inside North Korea most people
as Rich As Trump would not be heavily
influenced by a 20 million dollar loan
regardless the fact that Trump managed
to keep the debt secret for so long
underscores how weak the government's
ethics safeguards are how difficult they
are to strengthen and how easily Trump
could Barrel right through them as he
runs for president again in
2024. so there are a few issues here
I would say that there are four issues
here number one
is this also still just the tip of the
iceberg this has been a question as far
as Trump's taxes go now for more than
five years what we what we know is
already really bad and every time we
learn a little bit more
we are brought inevitably to the
question of how much more is there that
we don't even know about is this that's
issue number one issue number two
this was hidden
that this was deliberately hidden and uh
that is a problem number three the
sudden rapid payoff of the debt while
having made no progress on the debt for
a very long period of time what was the
reason for the apparent sense of urgency
it would be important to learn about
that and then number four I maybe I
skipped I don't know number four the
North Korea connection and is it
possible that this might have influenced
in some way Donald Trump's Obsession
quite frankly with uh Kim Jong-un and
North Korea and the meetings and the
handshakes and all of that stuff again
as the article says normally someone
this Rich isn't going to alter their
behavior dramatically over 20 million
but we have good reason to suspect
Trump's not actually as rich as he
claims to be
and also because it was hidden it only
raises the alarm around that as well the
uh by the way it is continuing to to
stun and uh uh you know just shock that
the obsession from the right
is with Hunter Biden's laptop and
references they claim are to Joe Biden
for which there is no proof and
meanwhile we have all of this actual
proof and financial records where there
is not even a doubt that it's all about
Trump Trump's name is on all of it
refuses to release his tax returns we
figure out he owes money to South Korea
it's a North Korean linked company he
hit it uh and then you've got examples
Saudi Arabia Russia China all these
different things
we have to look at what might be but
there is no evidence has anything to do
with Joe Biden in documents it is
continued hypocrisy this is almost
certainly only the tip of the iceberg
and indeed if those tax returns ever
leak
I'm not saying leak them to anyone I'm
just saying if they leak
I would expect way more of exactly this
type of stuff uh Donald Trump has had a
mental breakdown over being called out
accurately for the things he said about
the Constitution now let's back up just
a moment to make sure we're all on the
same page reporting accurately described
Donald Trump's demands for a newer a new
election or to be reinstated as
president of the United States based on
the hunter Biden Twitter files which
were a complete and total flop
in a post on Truth social which we
looked at yesterday and I will show you
again Donald Trump actually says quote a
massive fraud
uh a massive fraud of this type and
magnitude allows for the termination of
all rules regulations and articles even
those found in the Constitution he said
it he clearly said it Trump was
criticized for saying it because it's
dangerous and it's outrageous and it's
the metaphorical defecation on the
Constitution that he was accurately
described as partaking in and Trump
flipped out yesterday on Truth social
truth essential lying trying to deny and
of course typing in all capital letters
this is starting to be Kanye West level
stuff or maybe the Kanye West stuff is
actually Donald Trump level stuff I
don't know take a look at this insane
rant Trump says quote the fake news is
actually trying to convince the American
people that I said I wanted to terminate
the Constitution this is simply more
disinformation and lies just like Russia
Russia Russia and all of their other
hoaxes and scams what I said was that
when there is massive and widespread
fraud and deception as has been
irrefutably proven in the 2020
presidential election by the way it
hasn't steps must be immediately taken
to right the wrong Only Fools would
disagree with that and accept stolen
elections Maga and then we enter all
caps insanity quote simply put if an
election is irrefutably fraudulent it
should go to the rightful winner or at a
minimum be redone we're open and blatant
fraud is involved there should be no
time limit for change Trump continuing
in all caps we want people who quote
legitimately he won the election I don't
know why he puts legitimately in quotes
I don't know that the quotes mean what
he thinks they mean we want people who
legitimately won the election to lead
our country not people who had to cheat
in order to win that I agree with and we
got that person Trump is like your
conspiracy theorist uncle
except instead of being some random guy
that you see twice a year
it's the former president of the United
States who's putting this stuff out and
of course
Trump did say the thing that now he says
he didn't say he may not have said
terminate the Constitution but he said
terminate parts of it when you want the
original post was quote
so with the big with the revelation of
massive and widespread fraud and
deception in working closely with big
tech companies the DNC and the Democrat
Party
do you throw the presidential election
results of 2020 out and declare the
rightful winner
or do you have a new election a massive
fraud of this type and magnitude allows
for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles
even those found in the Constitution
our great quote Founders did not want
and would not condone false and
fraudulent elections
he said it
it was dangerous it horrified the world
and even some Republicans he was called
out
now he's denying it because he's Furious
this is getting worse and worse and
worse and many Republicans don't even
believe that this is disqualifying in
terms of his chance or possibility at
once again being president of the United
States
will have the posts the clips and all of
it on our Instagram which you can find
at davidpakman show also make sure
you're subscribed on our YouTube channel
we are heading towards 2 million
subscribers on YouTube that's
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's great to Welcome to the program
today Oren etcioni who's the founding
CEO of the Allen Institute for
artificial intelligence I really
appreciate your time today thank you
it's my pleasure good always good to
talk to humans yeah exactly right so I
mean okay let's for for some in our
audience who maybe have a general sense
of the idea of artificial intelligence
the term machine learning which I know
you have a you have a particular opinion
about and the these sorts of issues I
think they may have a general awareness
that there are people who are very
scared about the potential of an
artificial general intelligence and
there are others who have a very
optimistic view of those same
possibilities as maybe bringing Homo
sapiens to a new level of learning and
capabilities and medical advancements
Etc can you kind of lay out the the goal
posts or the guide posts as the term may
be of the perspectives on this issue
those who are pessimistic versus
optimistic what is the Crux of this
disagreement
well the way I think about it is that
the computer is a pencil okay it's a
very big pencil it's a very
sophisticated tool is what I'm trying to
say and as with any powerful tool it can
be used for good uh or for bad so there
are people who worry about its impact on
jobs uh losing jobs on privacy losing
privacy uh the bias that it potentially
can exhibit in its algorithms so that's
on the one side and then there are
people who can see its potential for
discovering vaccines like the the covet
vaccine AI helped there and see that
benefit there's also a group of people
who really don't think of it as a tool
they think that somehow this uh pencil
is going to escape and become a death
star and I uh a little bit mocking of
that point of view because uh I think
that it really is just a tool that's
super interesting because it's we'll get
to the why AI might be an exception but
in Neil postman's book technopoly which
I think is from the early 90s he has a
very similar perspective in general
about new technologies which is there's
sometimes this idea of new technology
comes forward some people theorize or
speculate about possible negative
consequences the next step is well let's
figure out a way to get the positive but
not the negative and his view is that
all the positive and negative will all
exist it's a question of implementation
regulation planning and management
essentially that you can't only have the
good without the bad where some say AI
is different is at least the theoretical
ability
of an artificial general intelligence to
learn more quickly more rapidly in a way
that gets it Beyond whatever it's sort
of initial I don't even know if
programming is the right term you'll
tell me if that's even the right word to
use and so it's sort of outside of you
know social media social media is
created it exists within certain bounds
it will have good and bad and we can
regulate and manage the difference at
least in theory with artificial
intelligence would be that it can itself
go beyond the guidelines and the borders
that humans set for it does that make it
different
well let's first of all start with the
fact that there is a universal and
understandable fear about our role as
humans and technology and this goes all
the way back to the Jewish legend of the
Golem uh who is this uh robot and to
Frankenstein and so on so for centuries
we've been worried in various ways that
technology is going to have this uh
outsized role now uh it is possible it
is conceivable that one day that'll
happen so now the question is how close
or far are we from that uh apocalyptic
vision and my assessment to somebody
who's been working on this for 30 years
and who's very steeped in this
technology seeing you know the latest
thing as of just a few days ago is chat
GPT which is this program you can have
these amazing exchanges with me maybe
we'll talk about that but my assessment
is that we are still decades if not
centuries away from that Vision so
really what AI is today is a lot more
like the next generation of software so
again super powerful uh changing the
world you know your your iPhone and so
on but still very much a tool that we
can use and and the notion that it'll
somehow uh escape and become a lot more
than we expect is not really Based on
data it's based on anxiety when you look
at the data when you look at what these
computers can do they're uh amazing but
they're not autonomous right even take
the the notion of self-driving cars
autonomous vehicles other than the fact
that they're not yet ready for prime
time and effective you still tell the
car where to go right it'll keep you
safer than ever eventually but it
doesn't suddenly decide okay you know I
want to go to Cleveland
yeah and I can tell you as a Tesla
driver it's not uh exactly something to
write home about right now that the
technology which I which I know you're
aware of
um there are some who I don't know if
are actually taken seriously by folks
like you like Ray Kurzweil who for more
than a decade has been saying we're
actually now in that phase that you say
is decades or even maybe hundreds of
years away we just can't tell because
when you're in the middle of Rapid
change it just seems slower and in
retrospect we will realize it you don't
agree with that you don't believe that
that time you're describing is taking
place right now
I I not only not agree with that but
again I I caution to look at the data
right so what is uh Kurzweil who again
has an impressive uh history and
Technology what's his basis for saying
that and uh you can also look at him uh
saying a number of other amazing things
like we've reached the point where we're
going to live forever and so on I would
say that he's a very optimistic
individual Fair okay that's that that's
fair to say uh let's talk a little bit
about you mentioned the the chat
technology
um the touring test is for those who are
not familiar sort of an idea of when
does an artificial when when does an AI
type technology get good enough at
mimicking human conversation such that
an actual human like you or I wouldn't
be able to tell that we are not speaking
to another human and folks wrote in and
they said well you know you should ask
about our our Siri and Alexa like that I
think the answer is is certainly not
right is it would you agree that they
are not at that level
Syrian Alexa are are very simple but
this is something that's rapidly
changing changing so uh chat GPT which
is this new uh chatbot uh considered the
best chatbot ever it's uh reached you
know more than a million users in five
days it's freely available on the
internet uh that one is getting close to
passing the Fable Turing test is that
as big a milestone
as Decades of literature make it out to
be or is it a curiosity that is
self-contained enough that it does not
necessarily mean okay now that gets us
to some particular next level
that is a great great question and I
think the answer is that we've learned
that various
limits that we've set where we believe
gosh a computer will never do that uh
get crossed and that's in 1997 a
computer beating Gary Casper of the
world champion in chess right uh more
recently a few years back beating the
world champion and go uh there was a
recent computer program that plays the
strategy game of diplomacy and now we
have the Turing test but each time we
realize that the computer is picking up
an aspect of intelligence but not the
whole human level thing and so
particularly about the Turing tests uh
New York Times Reporter John Markov said
that the Turing test is a test of human
gullibility right so it is uh
interacting in a way that seems human
but the these programs don't really
understand what's going on
when we think about the different ways
that artificial intelligence at a level
that's slightly ahead of where it is now
but not yet at what you're describing to
be decades or hundreds of years away
when we think about some of those
possibilities there's all sorts of
different fields that we could talk
about if we talk about the medical field
and the idea of using
machine learning or whatever better term
we may have for it as well as a big data
when it comes to Patient data and
um learning an algorithm of questions
that could be answered by a potential
patient the idea of incredibly accurate
diagnosis often comes up in lots of
literature as a use for this type of
technology and that it would take out
the emotion that that is there to some
degree in a so-called real doctor and
that there's other benefits
in the field of medicine specifically is
that interesting to you is it likely or
is there something big that's missing
from those uh hypotheses that actually
makes that not a very likely uh outcome
in the next five to ten years with such
technology
I I think this is a great example of how
powerful and beneficial computers can be
along two Dimensions first of all we can
get much better diagnoses as you
suggested based on more data and more
analyzes and secondly we can also make
it much more widely available there's so
many rural areas remote countries and
regions where the kind of medicine that
we're used to is just not available uh
and it's it's expensive to do it with
humans so if we can build programs
accessible over the Internet that can
help that's uh fantastic now I I think
that the best use of this certainly in
the foreseeable future isn't just the
computer uh taking over completely but
my favorite definition of AI is not
artificial intelligence it's augmented
intelligence so imagine that you have a
doctor with their experience with their
empathy being aided with this uh in the
fatigable assistant that reads all the
millions literally millions of papers uh
coming out that's Gathering all these
statistics and it's making
recommendations to the doctor would you
rather have your human doctor or your
human doctor with this incredible tool
at their disposal it's a no-brainer it
is I guess to play Devil's Advocate the
trend of doctors sitting there looking
at a screen rather than the patient is
already pretty bad and and if the
logistics of having the AI help have the
more sucked into the computer screen
maybe the experience won't be better but
maybe the outcome would I don't know
well again a wonderful point but I would
say this a ultimately we do care more
about the outcome particularly when it
comes to critical things but two the
reason that they're on the computer so
much is because they have all this
paperwork to fill out yes this is not a
product of AI now ai systems are coming
out right now uh that actually help to
automatically fill out the paperwork so
I think in the very near future we'll
have the computer less uh sorry we'll
have the doctor uh interesting slip
there we'll have the doctor Less on
their computer doing that and more able
to engage with with the patient I think
I think that would be that would be a
good thing last thing I want to ask you
about there all of these issues
ultimately end up being political right
stem cell research becomes political and
so does vaccines and every everything
becomes political is it safe to assume
and or is it already happening that the
political lines around AI are are that
those who are more conservative in their
world view are against this type of
Technology they want to try to ban it in
advance or prevent its development and
that those who are more socially liberal
or Progressive are more open to it or is
it falling along different political
lines
wow uh
I've never been asked that question so
David a wonderful question and it is
actually scrambling the political
spectrum and let me quickly illustrate
why yeah on the liberal side there's a
lot of concern about bias racism sexism
and these computer programs these AI
programs are data based and so they
sometimes absorb bias from their data so
there's a lot of concern there and on
the conservative side there's a lot of
concern about geopolitical tension and
the fact that China and others are are
attempting to become superpowers if not
uh dominant in Ai and so there's a very
strong sense that we need to invest
heavily in it uh both for economic
reasons and for National Security so
there are people all over the Spectrum
and it doesn't break out neatly we have
been speaking with Dr Oren etcioni who's
the founding CEO of the Allen Institute
for artificial intelligence super
interesting and I really appreciate your
time today and joining me
thank you so much
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so Fox
News propaganda is Tucker Carlson who
has spent over a year minimizing the
January 6th Trump riots
said yesterday on his program that he
can think of no no more Brazen attack on
our democracy
then when the Biden campaign asked
Twitter to take down nude pictures of
Hunter Biden which are against the law
in Most states and violated Twitter's
own policies on revenge porn
that's what Tucker Carlson is pointing
to as the most Brazen attack on our
democracy
you have to see this and then we'll
discuss it in 20 election Twitter did
this with the help of the FBI committing
censorship on behalf of one candidate
while working to hurt the other
candidate now one I'm sorry I'm sorry to
interrupt already
uh pay very close attention to the
language he uses and I'm going to back
it up just a few seconds because this is
critical to understanding the
propagandistic value of this E.I
committing censorship on behalf of one
candidate while working to hurt the
other candidate
it is hard to imagine a more Brazen
attack on our democracy than this huh
this is not how our system is supposed
to work in fact it's illegal
what Twitter did is a violation of the
First Amendment as well as of
established campaign Finance law they
never declared those contributions to
the Biden campaign that's a crime okay
I think there are five lies in there
it's only a 28 second clip of which we
listen to 26 seconds and I think there
are five lies in there think about the
number of things that he gets wrong and
then we'll talk about the absurdity
bigger picture of this there's I can
think of no more Brazen attack on our
democracy well I can think of one it's
January 6 which he minimized and of
course many other attempts by the Trump
Administration over the four years he
was president to suppress speech to
control the media kick out Jim Acosta
all these different things I can think
of many greater attacks on our democracy
than when the Biden campaign said to
Twitter Hey this is revenge porn these
are nude pictures of an individual who
did not release them please remove them
that's not really an attack on our
democracy number two
he says it's illegal it's not illegal
there I mean at this point it's been
what 72 96 hours since the Twitter files
uh was released and
um look at look at serious legal
commentaries I don't see anyone even
arguing that there was a crime here
number three this was a violation of the
First Amendment no uh we're talking
about a private company Twitter it's not
about the First Amendment the argument I
think Tucker and others are making is
that indirectly
because the government
told Twitter to remove the posts it is a
violation of the first amendment of
course it was the Biden campaign not the
government at the time so for about two
or even three different reasons and
layers it is not a violation of the
First Amendment then he says it violates
campaign Finance laws now I this one has
to be explained to be understood
his argument
I'm being as charitable as possible this
is the the best possible argument that
you could make his argument is
removing the posts of Hunter Biden naked
was financially valuable to the Biden
campaign like a campaign contribution it
would be called an in-kind contribution
and so it was supposed to have been
reported but it wasn't now you have to
prove that in court it's very shaky and
I can't imagine you could prove in court
that arguing for the removal of revenge
porn by Twitter is a contribution of
value to a particular campaign
Hunter wasn't running for anything and
it was against Twitter's own policies
and a crime in just about every state
now let's take a zoom out a little bit
the problem isn't really Tucker Carlson
specifically is it and what I mean by
that is we have a system that allows on
the one hand Tucker Carlson to speak to
a large audience on a set that you know
it it looks like this is news when you
look at this it looks like a news show
say things that are completely baseless
and meritless and without evidence in in
many cases and then if it ever leads to
a lawsuit and it goes to court
Fox News lawyers show up and they say
this is entertainment this is not news
and
um what he uses Hyperbole and
exaggeration as a tool to do an
entertaining show and it should not be
taken literally as though he is
reporting facts oh okay because Fox News
is really going very much out of their
way to frame all of this as being actual
news as the word suggests that's really
the bigger problem here and this is not
me calling for censorship I'm not saying
Tucker should be off the air but the
problem is that having it both ways all
the time presenting as news and listen
I'll be honest
much of the problem is media literacy
the people who watch Fox not from a
media criticism standpoint the way we do
but the people who watch Fox to learn
things and to get news
they don't realize that it's not news
they are the perfect marks for such a
deception and it's an endless Circle I
mean at this point how many times have
we talked about it the circle simply
continues and the latest now is this is
the greatest assault on our democracy
what about January 6th never mind dozens
of other things that happened under the
Trump Administration nope
it's when the Biden campaign said hey
this is illegal revenge porn and it
violates your own policies please remove
it whoa the biggest scan I'm trying to
is could this be potentially bigger than
Obama gate
which by the way I still don't know what
that is it seems those are really the
big scandals and Hillary's emails this
is the alternative world
alternative Universe better set in which
the modern right wing currently lives
hey uh you might be excited to learn
Kerry Lake who lost her race to be the
Arizona governor she now has a lawsuit
she has a lawsuit ladies and gentlemen
she appeared on the Steve Bannon real
America's voice War Room program I still
don't even know what that is but listen
to this Insanity a friend of mine texted
me two days ago
he said he lives in Arizona said I was
in Arizona at my local
car mechanic place getting my car tuned
up and in the waiting room they had
Steve bannon's show on
mind blown I have never heard of such a
thing okay Steve baden's show
Trump attorney Christina Bob is there
and Carrie lake is there
and Kerry Lake declares they are ready
to go with a lawsuit
now what is the lawsuit going to do I
have no idea
the election in Arizona was certified
yesterday
Kerry Lake lost Katie Hobbs will be the
governor but folks they have a lawsuit
is this a grift let's see if we can
figure it out how possibly can a
republican attorney general sit there
and a governor sit there and allow this
Fiasco people in Arizona have to
understand some Independence and
Democrats you look like idiots on the
world stage this looks like something
that would happen in the worst of banana
Republic's Cary Lake yeah before she
answers
one of the worst things that could
happen is a candidate who didn't win
ending up in office unfortunately that's
not going to happen because this
lawsuit's not going to go anywhere but
let's listen to it
yeah I mean the Optics and just a little
over an hour the Optics of them
um sitting there and signing their
signature can you imagine to this sham
election they did it back in 2020 two
years ago and many of us gasped and said
how could they do this why couldn't they
give more time to look into all of the
issues now fast forward 22. remember
there's never been enough time the audit
wasn't done correctly the recount wasn't
appropriate there was barbecue sauce on
the ballots and they still counted you
know two today and we've got more issues
than we saw in 2020 in that sham
election we have just a blatant
sabotaging of election day a
disrespected disregarded
disenfranchisement of election day
voters none of this is true and if they
sit there and sign their names to this
sham Certification history will never
forgive them they will go down as as
three of the very worst in history yeah
it was signed Katie hop is officially
the Arizona governor-elect and she will
be Kerry Lake's Governor very soon
now that we know and by the way we're at
the top of the first inning getting to
the bottom of the FBI the uh doj and I
think CIA involvement intelligence
apparatus and law enforcement Steve
Bannon thinks now that the CIA is also
involved these people's brains are
filled with mayonnaise and by the way
pretty bad mayonnaise I would say
there's been apparatus involvement in
the coup d'etat in the 2020 election
because remember ladies and gentlemen
they all knew we had the receipts this
is the thing you have to understand we
were wiretapped they read our emails all
of it they knew we had the goods they
knew this is not just about a corrupt
and incompetent media it's about this in
2020 how does the Elon Musk now remember
and Bannon almost just jumping around
frenetically between topics the entire
they wiretapped us they spied on us
understand what happened it's really
simple what happened the Trump campaign
was in touch
in 2016 with so many suspected criminals
who themselves were being surveilled by
law enforcement
that the people on the Trump side of the
conversations were incidentally uh
surveilled in that way it's sort of like
if I right now as part of doing my show
regularly spoke to say organized crime
people
the organized crime people are under
surveillance would it be accurate for me
to say the FBI is spying on me no what's
happening is I'm talking to so many
suspects of the organized crime
investigation my side of the
conversation is getting picked up by the
FBI that's what happened
ask the release of this what's happening
on about President Trump's 2020 tied
directly to what's going on in 2022 in
Arizona ma'am
well I mean to watch what happened over
the weekend I think what what musk put
out the information he put out I think
it was a game changer and to watch these
silence on the part of the mainstream
media no silence it's just there's not
much of a story there it was revenge
porn and the Biden Campaign which was
not the government at the time tried to
have it removed so listen Katie Hobbs
will be the governor of Arizona that's
the good news if Kerry Lake continues
living in Arizona Katie Hobbs will be
Kerry Lake's Governor period that's the
story they had the audacity yesterday
yes to certify an election for Katie
Hobbs that Katie Hobbs won that's good
news Kerry Lake didn't win if Kerry Lake
somehow ended up Governor that would be
a very bad thing and it's disturbing
that we have to explain this to people
the person who got more votes should be
the governor it would be bad for
democracy if the loser
still got to be Governor it would be
aversion
of the participation trophies that these
very same people claim to be against we
have a voicemail number and that number
is 2192 David P here's a caller with a
very specific question take a listen to
this
hey uh David uh Sonny hey question for
you so this is made like more of a
medical expert question uh when it comes
to maybe and I I even though I am not a
medical expert I'm glad to answer as if
I were potential human hibernation the
pandemic and kind of people forcing
doors a lot a long time in the winter
when it's cold
you know is it possible like it's some
sort of like
how do I say like
you get what I'm saying like maybe
there's some topics or something yeah I
understand okay the idea is
we've got a pandemic and in the winter
it's flu season Etc I have coveted right
now as I talked about yesterday what if
I or we when it starts to be flu season
could hibernate could humans hibernate
skip the entire flu season first of all
if it were possible
I don't know that it actually saves us
from flu season it might just shift it
around I'm just not sure about that okay
that's number one but number two let's
talk about hibernation there is no
evidence that is very good
that humans are able to go into
hibernation which would be like an
extended state of
um uh torpor I think is the way that we
would say there's no evidence of that in
what would be called accepted Medical
Science right now the idea is widely
discussed it's been explored in science
fiction the idea of using some kind of
human hibernation uh or or reduced
metabolic state for long space travel
has been talked about these are not new
ideas but there are only speculative
commentaries that it's theoretically
possible you can find papers that say
you know ancestors to humans pre you
know pre-human ancestors
had the biological mechanics required
for hibernation and maybe with the right
technology or modifications it's
something that humans might be able to
do uh you know the the idea of cryogenic
preservation for people
um uh so that in the future if certain
diseases could be cured or whatever the
case maybe people could be reanimated
it's big topic big business but it is
quite speculative
um and uh that's sort of like where the
science is right now and much is being
researched but here's another thing
wouldn't that be very difficult socially
because even if you could
technologically and medically figure out
human hibernation
uh how how would that work socially and
culturally and psychologically it seems
like it would be a really difficult
thing I don't know that's just my sense
right now but uh an interesting question
nonetheless we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad the money on the bonus show is
just crazy you should see it on today's
bonus show Joe Biden has the idea
to make South Carolina the first
Democratic primary what does South
Carolina think of it we will talk about
that on the bonus show number two
remember Michael avenatti he's been
sentenced to prison for 14 years for
fraud and it is wild wild stuff our
friend Farren cousins who was brutally
assailed by avenatti is thrilled and we
will also talk about nine million
Americans who were wrongly told that
they were approved for student loan debt
forgiveness how did it happen and what's
the story we will talk about all of it
and more on today's bonus show which you
can access by signing up right now now
you could do it later I would do it
right now at joinpakman.com
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC